where's your master I don't deal with
domesticated I eat the [ __ ] ain't got no
master but I do have your little tune
show me the idol show me the Redeemer
you go mate
hey yo hand it over I got a hot date
don't do late monkeys got a date what
what what what what what the Swiss
[ __ ] chocolate Pig
buon appetito
[Music]
I want every [ __ ] cop in this [ __ ]
City after that grab my chassis noxee
[Music]
damn
do it
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's about bloody time let's see what we
got
moksha
just as yama described it true freedom
lies beyond
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
first of all I want to say a big thank
you to all the teams who worked very
very very hard on creating all old es
all this world again thank you to all
these these teams behind us I want also
to say thank you to Eve with all my
heart
thank you for making this happen this is
this is just amazing and also a special
thanks to the fans of being good and
evil for sticking with us for so long
about party time 15 years almost so
welcome to system 3 our story takes
place before the birth of jade in a
multi-ethnic multicultural human society
in a distant solar system it is a time
when corporations create hybrids in
their labs and enslave them to colonize
the stars in order to compete for power
and cosmic resources with our crew of
crazy and unforgettable characters we
fight in the name of freedom and the
right to determine our own fate among
the stars and we will helm massive star
ferrying vessels through territories as
spectacular as they are dangerous
we've been working very hard on just on
the technology during three years and
today we have a seamless online
playground where we can travel across
space at the speed of light we can
explore mysterious cities and discover
undone lands by ourselves or with
friends and we want you to participate
in the making of this great adventure
join our space monkey program
today and help us make beyond good and
evil a world that will challenge us and
bring us together four thousand
adventure thrills and firm and this if
just join us Jesus thank you thank you
okay congratulation you guys you know
Gabrielle and Michelle you've done a
fantastic job
it's amazing what I've been you've been
able to achieve and you and I and all
the teams and the power of creating
games that will amaze all the gamers and
I think video games can help us to grow
and to get better so thank you very much
thank you congratulations
fun